remember we're talking about things
going up and things going down or things
doing neither which we call start of s
stationary thank you very much so here's
our function it's a cutie okay and what
we're asked to prove is that it's always
for its entire domain an increasing
function it's always going up right and
on the basis of what we prove here we
want to make a comment about how many
roots this thing has okay so let's start
one step at a time again when we're
thinking about functions and whether
they're increasing or decreasing going
up or going down what's our first step
first step differentiate thank you good
morning are you can't do very much you
can't make any interpret statements
until you have a derivative right
because then you can take all right well
now that I know what the derivative is I
could make some statements draw some
conclusions from there so here you go
it's a standard holiday me order you do
the student three logs out the Frog 33 x
squared plus one that's what happens if
he acts and that good morning negative
one just drops off it contribute happy
times now I have this I have this photo
what does this have to do with this what
does monotonically always increasing
what does it mean about gradient always
it means it's always bigger than 0
that's all I need that's all I need
right so i can say 3x squared this is
like a former where do i could do it a
bit quicker if i wanted to cry it's
greater than or equal to 0 in the domain
that i'm talking about namely all the
real values of x okay it only hits 0
when x is exactly equal to 0 so then
equal to 0 at one point so if i add one
to the left hand side like so I lose my
equality to the boundary right now I am
definitely wait positive okay but this
is just my expression for F dash yeah
okay therefore my grading is always
positive therefore my astonishin is
always increasing okay so i'll just
write that down yeah sure it just means
always always it's my it's my technical
proper synonym for always doing the same
thing and not changing just like
monetary means talking same tone as in
one tone monitor okay and so this I'm
just trying to be careful to interpret
what's going on and not rely too much on
the notation and this is why we
introduce our table before so you can
see all the parallels of language what
this actually means is the great is
positive for all real values of x okay
which is by definition okay it's always
increasing the gradients always positive
so the function is monotonic increasing
you can actually say it is an increasing
function like that's actually another
way of yet another way of describing it
because it's a function the only thing
ever does is increase so I'm going to
call it an increasing function okay now
excuse me I'm going to take this some ID
here and I don't need to actually know
precisely what this looks like in order
to make a statement about how many roots
there oh okay um don't try this but
let's just reason through this for a
second right and we know about a whole
bunch of different kinds of functions
right that's too small okay lots and
lots of different kinds of functions for
instance if you have a linear function a
linear functions right a linear function
is either increasing or decreasing or
neither right I type it going up or it's
going down or it's just horizontal if
it's vertical it's not really any of
those it's a bit of a special case but
the important thing is whichever it is
it's always doing whatever it's doing
what is that why is a linear function
always going to be doing
one or the other or the other okay so so
firstly we can say well look it's just
straight it's not changing where it's
move you around right but I can argue it
the same way i did here I think about
like this okay if you've got a straight
line every straight line is I can write
in this form right yes did you with that
when I do the same thing that I did here
and say well I'm going to argue for the
derivative right what's F dash in this
case it's just a number and it's just
the constant did you get it it's just a
constant it's always going to be doing
the same thing depending on what value
it is if n is positive increasing and
decreasing m's negative decreasing and
if n 0 then you just have your
horizontal always stay on your life but
the important thing is it's always doing
that okay now if you have a parabola
right note parabola is monotonically
increasing or decreasing across its
entire domain why is that because it's
always going to change at some point
right where is it going to change its
going to change at the vertex also known
as the turning point right and because
it's called the turning point we know
it's going to go down then up or vice
versa right oh yeah ok now linear
functions always doing one of the other
quadratics always going to change
halfway through okay but we get to
cubics or if i increase the power any
arbitrary about right if what I've got
is strictly increasing so it's this kind
of scenario right when you compare these
two do you see you can only ever have
one solution one root for a linear
function right because it can't turn
around like a quadratic wires to give
you another one does that make sense in
order to have multiple solutions you
need that turning point so you pass
through the Axis and then you come back
and you can hit the access again does
that make sense so what you think about
how many roots will something have if
it's monotonically increasing it doesn't
matter if it's like
okay it's going to be like this if it's
monotonically increasing it might do it
sort of a bit slower something like that
IQ could look like that okay but the
important thing is it never turns right
it's always increasing so how many
routes what's the maximum number of
routes we have the maximum number is one
I think it's 120 but you're missing all
monotonically decreasing okay does that
make sense by the way so we can just
write this conclusion right there for f
of X must have exactly one room this is
not the way I phrase the question but
you can also use this same fact has been
to argue that there has to be a solution
it has to be a solution think again
about the quadratic right some
quadratics don't have solutions they
don't have roots what kinds of quadratic
positive definite or negative definite
right in other words you've got a
discriminant which is negative so
therefore no more games and but if you
are always increasing always decreasing
you can't help it you have to get the
access somewhere right and so this is
another way of arguing actually when you
have a function like this therefore not
only does it have exactly one route but
it has to have a room how's that
somewhere I don't even need to know
where it is but it exists it has a
solution okay so it's a really simple
idea like you know almost nothing about
this but you can already draw some
important conclusions about it